بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ابن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء لمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو ملوك ورؤساء وامراء ورؤساء حكومات
الدول العربيه الشقيقه معالي السيد احمد
ابو الغيط امين عام جامعه الدول العربيه
السيدات والساده السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
بدايه اتوجه بالشكر لاخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود ولسمو ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان ال سعود رئيس مجلس الوزراء على
حفاوه الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه كما اود ان
اعرب عن خالص التقدير للجهود المخلصه التي
بذلها اخي فخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون
رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه الشقيقه في سبيل دعم العرب العمل
العربي المشترك خلال تراس الجزائر لقمه
العربيه الاخوه الاعزاء لقد مرت منطقتنا
خلال السنوات الاخيره بظروف استثنائيه
قاسيه هدلت على نحو غير مسبوق امن وسلامه
شعوبنا العربيه
واثارت في نفوس ملايين العرب القلق الشديد
على الحاضر والمستقبل لقد تاكد لكل ذي
بصيره ان الحفاظ على الدوله الوطنيه ودعم
مؤسساتها فرض عين وضروره حياه لمستقبل
الشعوب وم قدراتها فلا يستقيم ابدا ان تظل
امال شعوبنا
رهينه للفوضى والتدخلات الخارجيه التي
تفاقم من الاضطرابات وتصيب جهود التسويه
الازمات بالجود
ان الاعتماد على جهودنا المشتركه وقدراتنا
الذاتيه والتكامل فيما بيننا لصياغه حلول
حاسمه لقضايانا اصبح واجبا ومسؤوليه كما
ان التطبيق مفهوم العمل العربي المشترك
يتعين ان يمتد ايضا للتعامل مع الازمات
العالميه وتنسيق عملنا لصاحب منظومه
الحوكمه الاقتصاديه العالميه وفي القلب
منها مؤسسات التمويل وبنوك التنميه
الدوليه التي ينبغي ان تكون اكثر استجابه
لتحديات العالم النامي اخزن في الاعتبار
ان حاله الاستقطاب الدولي اصبحت تهدد
منظومه العولمه التي كان العالم يحتفي بها
وتستدعي للواجهه صراعا لفرد الايرادات
وتكريس المعايير المزدوجه في تطبيق
القانون الدولي اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسموك لقد تابعنا بالحزن والالم تصاعد
حده بعض الازمات العربيه خلال الفتره
الماضيه لا سيما ما ينتج عن اعمال التصعيد
غير المسؤوله من قبل اسرائيل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واخرها ما شهداه قطاع غزه
وبينما تؤكد مصر استمرار جهودها لتثبيت
التهدئه الا اننا نحذر من ان استمرار
اداره الصراع عسكريا وامنيا سيؤدي الى
عواقب وخيمه على الشعبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي على حد سواء ولعله من الملائم
ان نعيد اليوم تاكيد تمسكنا بالخيار
الاستراتيجي بتحقيق السلام الشامل والعادل
من خلال مبادره السلام العربيه وعلى اساس
قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومطالبه اسرائيل
بناء الاحتلال واقامه دوله الفلسطينيه على
حدود الرابع من يونيو 1967 وعاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه
واشتغلت كذلك ازمه جديده في السودان
الشقيق تنذر اذا لم نتعاون في احتوائها
بصراحه طويل متابعات كارثيه على السودان
والمنطقه كما تستمر الازمات في ليبيا
واليمن بينما بما يفرض تفعيل التحرك العرب
المشترك لتسويه تلك القضاء على نحو اكثر
الحاحا من اي وقت مضى وفي نفس السياق فان
عوده سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه تعد
بمثابه التفعيل العملي للدور العربي وبدء
مسيره عربيه لتسويه الازمه السوريه
استنادا الى المرجعات الدوليه للحل وقرار
مجلس الامن رقم 22 54 اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه مع ادراكنا ان الامن القومي
العربيه هو كل لا يتجزا فقد حان الوقت
لاخذ زمام المبادره للحفاظ عليه بما في
ذلك من خلال الخطوات المهمه اللي بادرت
بها دولنا في الفتره الماضيه لضبط ايقاع
العلاقات مع الاطراف الاقليميه غير
العربيه التي نتطلع منها خطوات مماثله
وصادقه بما يسهم في تحقيق الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه ختاما يؤكد ان مصر
بما يعتموه عنها على الدوام ستدعم بكل صدق
والاخلاص جميع الجهود الحقيقيه لتفعيل
الدور العربي ايمانا منها بان المقاربات
العربيه المشتركه هي الوسيله المسلى
لمراعاه مصالحنا وتوفير الحمايه الجماعيه
لشعبنا ودفع مسيره التنميه خطوات كبيره
للامام شكرا لكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات